hi I'm Greg I'm John The Wizard of lies
Oh
starring huh yo really huh really plays
a wizard please bet you know it's a
Bernie Madoff story oh good yeah all
right yeah let's do it let's get some
financial crisis in our jams
this silence talking about giving you a
hundred million dollars that's not gonna
do it
150 lucked out anybody can 175 I wish I
could have you know
275 300 million dollars so funny we
gotta go if you vote for us we just good
things about it while she you're an
eight-year-old you shouldn't be asking
me questions like that it's a fraud
basically just a big party scheme
what's a Ponzi scheme 50 billion with a
big do you understand what he's done if
the feeling is entirely being hated you
got yourself into trouble you couldn't
get it why does the world hate me they
all think I'm some kind of a mastermind
take it as a compliment
you were never suspicious of your phone
you never see me how I didn't know
you're the FBI did you
no you don't understand you don't have
to understand what you do with the money
I thought you were gonna protect me
forever
[Music]
whoa it's made of beasts and what was
that
love you now three two count one go deep
he just started me like roadkill how do
you beat got to guilty he took our
entire life site down sweet
guilty how could you do this sixteen
years I kept the secret for my wife my
sons I was able to do that and maintain
any degree of sanity I always know when
I think about
[Music]
I smell Golden Globe nomination it's
nice to see Robert De Niro really throw
it down again on role [ __ ] it looks like
Bernie made oh yeah really well that's
Bernie Madoff's hairstyle but yeah
that's dinero's real I was gonna say
just I don't know just looks convincing
to me
yeah it looks it looks like you really
got to cut that my grandpa's hair this
looks intense as [ __ ] a sympathetic
portrayal of the man who's screwed over
people yeah or at least a darkly human
what is the man behind the fucked-up
admit it feels a little sympathetic
toward like the first minute at first
like few seconds where he's like
negotiating how much the guy should
pitch in I thought I'd like most of the
trip would be like that side of Bernie
Madoff here wolf of Wall Street yeah
it's like he's making good a man for a
wife the good fellow Rhys Rhys
inevitable you know this one's like wow
this is the portrayal of how guilty he
felt dark a human portrait of a man who
destroyed many lives it's probably gonna
be good HBO's original films are really
good I'm excited for this because I mean
it's might not really make full sense
but Pacino has done a few HBO films okay
Angels in America you know no Jack and
there's another one that was a biopic
Ana de niro transferring into this I
think this is a great direction for De
Niro you know like as the narrows very
much hit or miss these days yeah bad
grandpa dirty grandpa dirty grandpa
Johnny Knoxville that one was actually
fine we should match the two up yeah I
grabbed one meets the dirty Greer plug
and Zac Efron did like round up not like
this movie and Michelle Pfeiffer
couldn't sell that was like age makeup
or if she just looks that much older now
I mean she might look that much older
but she isn't like I thought she was
still looks good oh yeah no I would
still she still had the you know
Catwoman outfit
like a real person that's right they
were in the family you could Bissell
they were in Luke based songs the family
I just kind of remember what movie they
did together yeah yeah yeah finally
getting back together for another
adventure yeah I'm interested to see is
because I I know a Bernie Madoff
I'm a must be surprised if you live in
America and you're over the age of 18
and you haven't heard huh at least heard
his name yeah but I don't know like the
details that a lot of stories have you
know been inspired by yeah this seems
like something he had a man cave would
probably touch on yeah yeah it's like I
remember when this was happening and now
especially in that sort of glut of
movies about these things you know there
was like the smartest guys in the room
which was the Enron documentary and then
they may have no wolf of Wall Street and
what's Lizzie Adamek a movie the big
short the big funny with the other guys
touches on schemes yeah yeah so like
I've got a lot of these now collected up
in my head though it's been a while
since I've visited this particular tale
but it looks shot really well looks
intense De Niro I'm excited that he's
you know it's really I'm excited to see
a trailer words like didn't yours
keeping his oh yeah really looks like
he's portraying a character yeah I mean
it looks like a dark character study I
wonder who directed this yeah Vera
Levinson oh this could be good he's
worked with De Niro a lot a lot of films
I think I like all the films De Niro has
done with him I think he did sleepers we
have out to be here I know he did what
just happened what did you do back the
dog - yeah wag the dog
yeah he's worked with the narrow a lot
okay yeah this and he did the bad I've
heard a pretty good OAH and he did you
don't know jack with Pacino and I I
really really enjoyed that HBO film I
thought it was fantastic this is gonna
be good I have faith that this will be a
good HBO Philly trio makes great
material seems like they put a lot of
time
energy and money yes I've never even
seen the interview of Bernie Madoff only
seen pictures of her articles I've seen
a novel I don't we're gonna watch them
all in you know watch originally asked
we want to have the best review because
it's it's it's it's HBO films like this
that blow up YouTube channel we're gonna
do a marathon and then we're gonna make
our own documentary about it you know
like we're gonna start covering this
kind of news on our channel this video
was first requested from Matt tied in 78
nat titan are you so mad because he is
Zeus's other son that just got no
recognition
that's messed up losers had many
children yeah it was one of the man time
yes Zeus got around and this was a pimp
he's [ __ ] a lot yeah so that's why
Matt Tyne is mad cuz his dad wasn't
around he was taking care of Sam
Worthington the whole time alright you
can subscribe to the real rejection
notification bail reasons cheerio
narrator an Instagram social media
manager blum house and the real rejects
shout out to Mel Gibson ooh
when's he gonna make an HBO original
movie about somebody who [ __ ] up a lot
of people's lives he should do it about
a Jew Barry Levinson's Jewish Bernie
Madoff Jewish Mel Gibson should do a
Jewish movie I think that's the way I
think I think he wants like a learn
respect
he should use the good yeah none of this
just don't tell like a just the most
uplifting tales okay the great Jewish
man they're just a great [ __ ] and
everything was great and he was a
believer in Christ